a quiet place isn't perfect but there's
a lot it does right and one of my
favorite aspects of the film is the
opening sequence let's break down the
opening eight minutes and how it tells
us about the world of the film and sets
the stakes for the movie hi
the opening sequence divides well into
two parts the first is the scene in the
pharmacy that introduces us to the
family and sets us up with the minimal
necessary exposition to understand the
world the second part is the first
suspense sequence of the film we'll look
at each individually this video is
sponsored by audible click the link in
the description to get a free audiobook
today before we've even seen any part of
the film we get the day 89 title card
this type of title has almost become a
trope for apocalypse films so even the
mere use of it here gives the audience
some information about the setting a
significant or catastrophic event for
our characters or the world has occurred
89 days ago it also gives you a question
that you want the answer to right away
89 days since what the very first frame
starts feeding us some of the answers to
that question
the event was physically disruptive in
some way and things are bad enough that
no one has tried to put things back
together as evidenced by the grass
growing up through the traffic light the
second frame gives us some more
information about the setting a rural
area with a low population but it also
keys us into the fact that the event was
catastrophic enough that people couldn't
use their vehicles to escape or abandon
them perhaps because they were killed we
also get our first clue as to the unique
nature of this world the sand path shows
us that something or someone is present
but unless you've seen the trailer you
wouldn't yet know what it is used for
the next few shots are establishing
shots for the first scene we get more
clues about the nature of the event lots
of missing people and see a pharmacy
that has been mostly looted there are
some subtler clues about the nature of
the world that you might notice here
like the fact that the items with
noisier packaging like bags of chips
remain on the shelves we also see two
children trying very hard to be quiet
but that the youngest child isn't quite
as careful as the oldest child but as
far as we know they could be playing a
game we learned through visual cues and
sound design that Regan the
oldest girl is deaf there's an
interesting bit of sound design used for
this since the sound design for this
scene and a lot of the movie in general
is incredibly quiet portraying the
audible perspective of a deaf person
might be difficult you could make things
completely silent but instead they opted
for a more obvious audible cue you're
going to have a hard time hearing this
if you're not wearing headphones or in a
theater with a good sound system but
when we're within reagan's perspective
the noise level is actually louder than
the rest of the scene but instead of
clearly hearing the noises in the room
all we hear is a deep muffled hum this
is also why we need the youngest child
to be noisily running around if the
entire family was completely silent for
this scene there would be nothing for us
to not hear from Reagan's perspective
another thing I love about how this
scene unfolds is the layered
introduction of a lot of the family
we're tracking the movement and action
of one of the family members and then
catch a glimpse of a new character in
the background it first happens here
this shot simply and effectively
communicates that one child is sick and
that the family is here for medicine the
camera racking focus implies an
association between the two subjects and
simultaneously we get another background
reveal of a new character the mother and
see her trying to be extremely quiet
which Clues us into the fact that the
children aren't just playing a game part
of what's great about film as a visual
medium is the way you can quickly layer
together information for the audience to
pick up on but many films fail to
utilize this efficiency soon after that
we get another shot where we learn
simultaneously that the boy isn't
seriously sick and that the family can
communicate via sign language the entire
first five minutes is a flood of
information for the audience but it's
presented in a layered overlapping and
motivated way that keeps it from feeling
too expository the sequence with the
youngest child drawing a rocket is
important for three reasons
first it's another clue about the
severity of the situation the family
wants to escape but can't for some
reason and a rocket ship is perhaps the
only possible escape from this
environment that a young child could
imagine
the second reason is that it creates an
emotional motivation for the youngest
child's obsession with the space shuttle
toy without this bit the fact that the
kid decides to play with a noisy toy
would seem motivated by a mere ignorant
but instead we get some context that
helps us sympathize with why the child
would be obsessed with the toy it also
gives us a meaningful moment between the
siblings which only makes the end of
this opening sequence more impactful the
moment immediately following this
continues to establish just how
seriously the characters take staying
quiet and simultaneously reveals the
father character in the background and
then we get a moment where the father is
introduced and the relationship between
the father and daughter is developed
this relationship will be perhaps the
most significant one in the film so it's
necessary to start developing this early
on then we get another moment that
reiterates just how serious a loud noise
would be and gives us a tiny bit of
foreshadowing
[Music]
it's selling the audience if they hadn't
thought about it yet that the toy could
make a loud noise and that would be
disastrous
this marks the transition to the second
part of the sequence five minutes in
we've been introduced to the characters
developed some of the relationships and
learned some of the basic rules of the
world so the last half of the sequence
is about two things creating the first
real moment of suspense in the film and
setting the stakes high a quiet place is
mostly a suspense film and there are
several ways of effectively generating
suspense you can generate suspense using
a feeling of uncertainty to create
anxiety in the audience but oddly you
can also generate a feeling of suspense
by creating certainty that an undesired
outcome will occur a quiet place often
uses dramatic irony to create this
suspense of certainty the shot of the
youngest child picking up the batteries
creates dramatic irony the audience
knows the batteries will go into the toy
and the toy will make a sound because we
know the movie wouldn't have put
emphasis on this detail if it wasn't
going to happen but the rest of the
family is completely unaware of the
impending disaster so we're left waiting
for something to happen that we don't
want to see happen and that suspense is
built further by drawing things out with
a simple scene of the family walking
through the woods in this scene we
learned the use of the sand we saw
earlier and that the family lives a good
distance from the town the music is more
mellow and sad than it is tense which
builds the dramatic irony the music
matches how the characters feel not the
audience's knowledge reinforcing the
idea that the characters are
unsuspecting of what the audience knows
will happen the music finally dies down
and we're bracing ourselves for the
sound the content looks on the mother
and daughter's face make it all the
worse for the audience note that by this
point we don't need to see a shot of the
toy making noise because we know what's
going to happen the suspense is extended
a moment longer by first showing the toy
in the back
ground while we're in Regan's audible
perspective and then we hear the sound
while the camera is on the father's face
because we already know what's going to
happen the focus can be on the emotions
and perspectives of the rest of the
family at this moment the suspense
created by the dramatic irony is
resolved the bad thing we knew is coming
has happened new suspense is now created
by uncertainty what will happen to the
child we experience Reagan's realization
of what's happening not through sound
but through her parents expressions
which gives us an idea of just how
terrible her situation would be living
in a world where sound is deadly but
where you can't tell if a noise is being
made
it's the audible equivalent of casting a
suspenseful scene in shadows as the
monster approaches we get very few
glimpses of it the focus remains mostly
on the family's perspective and
reactions this is great because what's
most important for the film ahead are
not the details of the monster but that
the audience establishes an emotional
connection with these characters because
the film has been so quiet and
restrained it gets to use contrasting
loudness to great effect here
and then it happens the tiniest bit of
hope that we held on to that the child
might be saved is dashed the sequence
ends with the death of the most
vulnerable character we've been
introduced to so far it communicates to
the audience that the movie will cash
the suspense checks that it writes the
audience knows that if someone dies in
the first sequence it would be
incredibly surprising if no one else
died by the end of the film and if the
movie is willing to kill off the
youngest cutest little kid any of the
other characters are potentially fair
game the original script didn't include
this opening eight minutes and pretty
much starts where the movie picks up
after the title card but I think this
sequence was a good addition because it
clearly shows the consequences of making
a sound early on which makes all the
subsequent scenes where characters are
trying to be quiet more tense this
sequence is an excellent example of how
exposition can be done efficiently and
visually in a way that isn't too
disruptive or obvious and how filmmakers
have to build and negotiate with an
audience's expectations for a movie
I'm headed to the beach on vacation for
a few days and an essential part of that
trip for me will be the audiobooks I
take along if audiobooks aren't a part
of your summer yet I want to encourage
you to use audible to get started
listening today while I'm at the beach
I'll be finishing up the broom of the
system by David Foster Wallace I've been
really enjoying the bizarre hilarious
journey it's taking me on go to
audible.com slash Thomas flight to sign
up with your membership you'll get one
credit a month to spend on any audio
book and that audio book is yours to
keep any credits you don't have we'll
roll over to the next month when you
sign up using my link in the description
or text thomas flight - 500 500 you get
your first credit for free use that
credit to get the broom of the system or
whatever else from audibles massive
selection that suits your fancy and get
started listening before the summer is
over so go to audible.com slash Thomas
flight or text
Thomas flight - 500 500 to get a free
book and a 30-day trial I'm always
looking for audio book recommendations
so leave yours in the comments below if
you're waiting for my next installment
in my directors before series I have one
about Christopher Nolan coming later
this month if you appreciate my content
and want to support its continued
creation go to patreon.com/scishow